Superhero movies present us with larger-than-life
heroes who overcome impossible odds to save
the day. The real heroes though are the actors
who don the outfits to bring these comic book
legends to life… Because the experiences
aren't always so pleasant. Here are some examples
of actors who have put on the super-suits,
but didn't particularly enjoy doing so.
Andrew Garfield
As the famous webhead in both Amazing Spider-Man
films, Garfield gave us a different look at
Peter Parker. But what Garfield didn't want
us to get a look at was his Spider-Man outfit
and how uncomfortable and unflattering it
was.
"I knew there were paparazzi taking terrible
unflattering shots of my, you know, everything,"
said Garfield, according to Digital Spy. “The
whole point of wearing a mask is you feel
free and you can be whatever you want and
you can be witty.”
But then he was made uncomfortable by the
fact that onlookers were getting butt shots
of him from many, many different angles. That’s
one way to get your Spider Sense tingling.
Chadwick Boseman
As the first, live-action version of Marvel's
Black Panther in Captain America: Civil War,
Chadwick Boseman had to squeeze into a black
catsuit in 90-degree weather. Boseman talked
to Cinema Blend about how certain stunts would
be physically demanding because of the suit.
"And every time they add a part, I'd be like
'you mean...you just gonna cut off my air
supply?' Like 'oh okay let me figure out how
to breath like that.'"
He also talked about how he had to get into
a "Zen space" in order to get through the
difficult stunts, since he'd have sweat rolling
down his body and was unable to scratch itches.
You'd think it would have been easy for him,
especially with those Vibranium claws.
Scarlett Johansson
Black Widow might have had red in her ledger,
but Scarlett Johansson had sweat in her socks.
Johansson said in an interview with Nightline
about the first Avengers movie, "It was so
hot, I would wring out my socks at the end
of the day."
That's gross, but also it's understandable
considering the fact that her Black Widow
costume was like a wetsuit and wasn't pleasant
in the heat. In fact, it got so hot that she
actually hallucinated for a bit while filming
a fight scene. Johannson also compared the
multiple costumes she had to tires, because
her stunts would wear each one down until
she needed to replace them. Pulling off all
of those hurricanranas couldn't have been
easy on those stitches.
Malin Akerman
As sweaty as some actors get in their costumes,
Malin Akerman's experiences in the Silk Spectre
costume for Watchmen were wholly different.
The skin-tight, black and yellow suit shows
off her physique while looking pretty badass.
But, according to Maxim, Akerman said that
the latex costume smelled terrible.
"I thought it was really f***ing hot at first.
Then I tried it on, and I thought it was really
f***ing uncomfortable. When you take it off,
it smells like a human condom," said Akerman.
And with those words, we can never see Watchmen
again without gagging just a little bit.
Olivia Munn
While donning costumes can empower superheroes,
it's another thing altogether to actually
get into them. Olivia Munn, who played Psylocke
in X-Men: Apocalypse, revealed on Conan that
it took a bit of help to get her into the
character's iconic purple costume. To be more
specific, it took the help of two women and
a lot of lube to get the outfit on. You'd
think that having to do that every time you
had to shoot a scene was embarrassing enough,
but the first time she got on set with the
veteran X-Men actors, she actually popped
the crotch on the suit—whoops.
Rebecca Romijn
In a 2003 interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Rebecca Romijn talked about how hard it was
to get the Mystique makeup applied for the
filming of X2: X-Men United. The process involved
four women and a little under eight hours,
effectively souring Romijn's mood as time
went on.
"When I first took this on, they told me it
would take ten hours."
"Six hours."
"Ten hours!"
The worst part, however, was the fact that
she was naked under all of the makeup while
everyone else got to wear outfits. At one
point, director Bryan Singer came into her
tent while she was bent over a chair and getting
her "crack touched up." She might been painted
blue, but we're willing to bet her face was
pretty red.
Margot Robbie
She may quite literally slay in her Suicide
Squad hot pants, but Margot Robbie was definitely
not a fan of them. While a lot of folks are
making her Harley Quinn out to be an overtly
sexual piece of eye candy, Robbie said that
Quinn likes the shorts "because they're sparkly
and fun" and not because she wants guys ogling
her.
"What?"
"As Margot, no, I don't like wearing that.
I'm eating burgers at lunchtime, and then
you go do a scene where you're hosed down
and soaking wet in a white T-shirt, it's so
clingy and you're self-conscious about it,"
Robbie told The New York Times.
Ben Affleck
Our newest Batman has made it known that he's
not a huge fan of the Batsuit he wore in Batman
v Superman: Dawn of Justice. While many a
fanboy would love to don the cape and cowl,
Affleck called it "the most humiliating, ridiculous
thing in the world." According to Total Film,
this is because the Batsuit was really a motion
capture suit that allowed for greater range
of movement. He even gave a nickname to the
suit and called it his "visual effects pajamas."
We understand that he might have felt it was
embarrassing to wear the outfit because it
didn't make him feel badass like Batman, but
at least there were no Bat-nipples.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which super-suit you think looks the
most uncomfortable...